Salut les naturalistes !
Avez-vous reconnucette bestiole ? Avec près de 3 cm de long,
elle est l'un des plus gros insectes qu'un
jardin puisse accueillir et c'est aussi
l'une des plus grandes espèces d'abeilles
d'Europe.
Pas de panique hein ! C'est totalementinoffensif.
Solitaire, cette espèce pond dansle bois mort
ou de vieilles charpentes qu'elle
creuse à l'aide de puissantes mandibules. Une
habitude dite xylocole qui lui vaut d'ailleurs
son nom d'abeille charpentière ou de xylocope violacé.
Abeilles et bourdons, ce sera doncle thème
de ce troisième épisode de notresérie
"La vie secrète du jardin". Générique !
Fourmis, guêpes, bourdons, abeilles,
frelons. Tous ces insectes font partis
d'un groupe que les spécialistes
appellentl'ordre des hyménoptères.
Ce mot tire sonorigine du grec ancien.
"Ptère" signifiantl'aile, et "hymen"
faisant référence au dieu de la mythologie
romaine qui présidait lesmariages.
Quel rapport me direz-vous ?
Chez la quasi totalité des hyménoptères,
les ailes antérieures et postérieures
sont couplées par une série de petits crochets.
En quelque sorte, les ailes sont mariées.
Retenons surtout qu'il existe des dizaines de
milliers d'espèces d'hyménoptères dans le monde
et que cette diversité peut aussi s'exprimer dans
un jardin, notamment chez les abeilles.
Alors bien entendu, nous connaissons tous l'abeille domestique
qui vit en colonie et que les apiculteursélèvent pour le miel.
Mais avez-vous déjà entendu
parler d'osmie ?
d'halicte ?
de colette ?
de mégachile ?
ou d'andrène ?
Les entomologistes, autrement dit
les spécialistes des insectes, différencient en
France environ 1000 espèces d'abeilles.
Près de90 % d'entre elles sont solitaires.
Ce qui veutdire qu'elles construisent
seules leurs nids pour y pondre des œufs.
Les trois quarts le font dansle sol.
Elles sont dites sabulicoles ou terricoles
selon leur préférence pour le sable ou laterre.
Chez les bourdons par exemple, qui sont
en réalité des abeilles particulièrement velues,
les nouvelles colonies naissent souvent
sous terre, dans des galeries de rongeurs.
D'autres abeilles préfèrent pondre dans depetites cavités,
dans du bois mort ou destiges sèches.
C'est le cas des osmies rousses
et cornues qui s'invitent volontiers dans
les tiges de bambou ou les bûches percées de nos
hôtels à insectes.
Dès que les œufs y sontpondus, l'entrée est bouchée
pour protégerles larves jusqu'au printemps suivant.
Pour attirer abeilles et bourdons au jardin,
il n'y a pas 36 solutions.
Il faudrades fleurs, aussi variés que possible
puisqueles abeilles adultes se nourrissent de nectar.
Certaines espèces sont dites éclectiques
etvisitent un grand nombre de plantes différentes
alors que d'autres au contraire,
sont liées àquelques espèces en particulier.
Comme toutesles abeilles n'ont pas des langues
de la mêmelongueur pour aspirer le nectar,
elles s'oriententvers des fleurs plus
ou moins profondes pour butiner.
Lierre, pois de senteur, sauge, tournesol,
bourrache,courge, ciboulette, mauve...
Vous aurez l'embarras du
choix pour les espèces ornementales : les arbresfruitiers,
les plantes aromatiques du potager ou
celle d'une prairie fleurie.
De plus, certainessoi-disantes "mauvaises herbes"
ont un rôle trèsimportant à jouer pour nos hyménoptères.
Un exemple : le pissenlit dont les fleurs apparaissent
dès le mois de mars dans les jardins.
C'est justement en mars que les reines des bourdons
sortent d'hibernation pour fonder une nouvellecolonie.
Elles sont parmi les premiers
insectespollinisateurs à s'activer
et les pissenlitssont une source
de nourriture indispensable pourelles.
La logique doit être la même avec les fleursde trèfle
qui finissent malheureusement
trop souvent coupées par nos tondeuses.
Alors bien sûr, identifier toutes les espèces
d'abeilles dans un jardin est un exercicedifficile.
Mais vous n'aurez aucun mal àvoir
qu'elles ne sont pas toutes pareilles.
C'est tout pour aujourd'hui.
J'espère quecet épisode vous a plu
et je vous donnerendez-vous pour le prochain
qui seradédié aux habitants de la mare. À bientôt !